hi there steve kaufman
and today and by the way i repeat this
at the beginning of my videos here if
you enjoy these videos please subscribe
to my channel i'm going to talk about
language learning
i'm going to be talking about
words and how we acquire them at least
how i think we most effectively acquire
them and it's a bit of a follow-up to a
video i did recently about how the
internet has changed how we learn
languages incidentally that video was uh
tweeted
about
by some people in sweden
so if i can get their names here a
certain kronholm and carla
filter i think with my glasses on victor
birkeland so i'm going to finish off
wing some
comments in swedish towards the end of
this video
however we had a discussion on our
format link where someone said i don't
see how steve can have so many known
words in whatever korean and i have lots
if you look at my statistics at link by
the way link is
lingq.com that's where i learned my
languages i'm connected with that site
as a co-founder i refer to it a lot some
people think that's unfair that i
shouldn't be promoting my website but
i'm very excited about it it's something
i started near the end of my
professional life which i'm very proud
of and it gives me a lot of satisfaction
because that's where i've been learning
languages for the last 10 years
and
in languages like russian czech korean
uh you know ukrainian i have 30 40 50
russian 90 000 known words according to
the statistics that we keep at link that
are generated automatically and just
basically assume that
if you don't save a word to your
database
or you if you move that word to known
then you know it
and so the person said how can you have
so many known words i've been studying
korean i only have whatever five
thousand and how can steve have forty
thousand or whatever the number is
and of course this is a very important
point because most of the words we learn
i'm convinced we learn them incidentally
all right the words that we deliberately
learn and study on flash cards that's a
small part of the words that we are at
least can learn should learn in fact if
we spend too much time deliberately
trying to master a few words we will end
up knowing fewer words
and so i liken it a bit too i don't know
if you play scrabble but the people who
play scrabble by trying to make very
little clever little words it if you
know where they get nine points ten
points and use two letters they lose the
idea in scrabble is to use up as many
letters as possible so that your
opponent doesn't get as many letters to
play with it's a volume thing and it's
the same in language learning the more
words you know the more words you can
guess at because
very often the new word that you come
across say at our
lesson pages link which is therefore
still blue
it might be a form of a word that you
already know or something that contains
components of words that you already
know so you don't need to save that word
because you can basically guess what the
meaning is and if you guess wrong or if
you have any doubt you can always look
it up again but i tend not to you know i
look at this word i say yeah i kind of
know what it means in this context fine
i'll take it and i don't even worry
about whether i know all of the possible
you know the full range or scope of that
word i know enough of this word to get
me through this content that i'm reading
and listening to because ultimately it's
this massive exposure to interesting
content content that is interesting to
me and yet that i can make sense of
within this context
that's what's going to make me improve
in the language that's going to give me
more and more exposure and so you want
to move as quickly as possible to where
you can kind of work through interesting
content you understand these words you
can guess at new words and pretty soon
all of a sudden texts that seemed
difficult three months ago are now
easier for you you are acquiring these
words incidentally
now
as i've said many many times for that to
work you have to move very quickly
through relatively uninteresting content
in order to get or you can focus on
things of interest to you which might be
history music literature whatever it is
that you're interested in in my own case
i'm very interested in history so i
spent a lot of time recently
reading interesting articles books
listening to stuff related to ukrainian
history and there's no question that i'm
improving i just finished having a very
good conversation with uh katerina in
dinipro and in fact i
i did a video with her some while ago
where and this would showed my level in
ukrainian and i'm going to ask her
perhaps the next time or whenever uh
that to ask her if she would do another
video with
us having a conversation in ukrainian
and you'll see how much my ukrainian has
improved my vocabulary my comprehension
my ability to use words not only which
words belong together but even getting
the grammar right the instrumental the
dative whatever all of this stuff is
falling into place because i'm just
consuming more and more words so uh you
know i liken it to a snowball you know
language learning is a volume thing it's
a big data kind of thing it's not
picking away at little knits nuts and
bolts trying to nail down this or that
making sure i
master this word i know it you know it's
got to be become part of my active
vocabulary stuff forget all that stuff
know enough of the word to get through
interesting content and then expose
yourself to as much as possible of stuff
that interests you compelling content
and then when you feel up to it start
using it and when you use it of course
you'll see where you're missing things
you're you're not totally confident
about this word or that where you use it
right or you use it wrong and then you
go back and listen some more and you're
just gathering like a snowball you're
just gathering and gathering more words
in language learning it's a bit like you
know the rich get richer and the poor
get poorer the more money you have the
more money you can make because you can
invest it and you can earn more and more
money because you have money on the
other hand
uh you know if you the same with words
so the more words you hold there was
just something flashed on my screen here
the more words you have the more words
you can learn the more of the jigsaw
puzzle of the language becomes clear the
more
fuzzy and unclear things you can now
start to focus on and make them clear
okay so yeah
after some of the uh
is also for putting them so there's some
practice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's all for today see you
next time thank you for listening
[Music]
you